Oh
for more than a decade biologists have
been able to turn stem cells into
beating heart cells in a petri dish and
bioengineers have had some luck getting
stem cells to grow on scaffolds to make
simple hollow organs like tracheas and
bladders but just how hard would it be
to make a large complex organ like a
heart from scratch getting beating
clumps of cells to organize into a
3-dimensional heart requires scaffolding
at the Massachusetts General Hospital in
Boston Harald OTT and his team start
with the scaffold that nature provides
they're using a technique called D
cellular ization to strip away all the
living cells from a heart the owner of
this specimen died only a few days ago
it will sit in a specialized vessel for
about a week
while chemicals wash away its DNA lipids
soluble proteins sugars and all other
cellular material the building if you
want to renovate it or repair it you go
in you knock down drywall or get rid of
you know cabinets and stuff like that
and basically we're going into the
matrix and doing that by profusing
solutions and detergents we're getting
rid of all the cells afterwards all
that's left is a pale white matrix of
collagen and other structural proteins
that once held everything together
stripping away the donor cells removes
the antigens that can cause the body's
immune system to reject the new organ
the scaffold can then be repopulated
with healthy new cells that are
immunologically matched to the patient
the team hopes to one day completely
reconstitute working hearts from a
scaffold like this but today they're
focused on how they might develop parts
of the heart using the same process
they've taken a valve and part of the
aorta from a decellularized heart and
send it on to a cadaveric heart so this
part here is the aortic group
including the aortic valve
and the a sending the order and this has
been DSLRs so this is a t-cell rise
graphed sewn onto a cadaveric human
heart and you can see here the right
coronary artery button in the left
corner artery button sewn onto that D
cell rice graft and the same thing here
this is the pulmonary artery and the
right ventricular outflow tract here of
the cadaveric heart
this is the graph that the seller eyes
to graft that has been sewn on to the
heart
Harold and his team want to check if
their graft would be able to do what
these structures do in real life
prevent fluids from flowing back into
the heart and feed oxygenated blood from
the aorta to the arteries that feed
hungry heart muscles they use a CT
scanner at the hospital next door to
take a look at their work Harold pumps
contrast fluid through the aorta to
check for backflow and to see if the
arteries that feed the heart muscle leak
the team knew in an emergency department
case could come through at any time so
they had to act quickly
okay back in the control room Harold
runs through his handiwork with
radiologists Brian go Joshua and what we
have here is a CT of this explanted
heart and you very nicely injected the
aortic root we can see that the you've
sewn in your syringe to this area just
to orient us I'm really quickly going to
put it into a 3d mode down here and then
window away so we can see what's left
let's just blow that up so
when you look at the sinuses of this ard
group does that look physiologic to you
what does the anatomy look like looks
pretty close to what I would expect in a
in a physiologic human in this you can
see it's very nice and smooth so what
matters most clinically is the the inner
luminal smoothness and really does look
pretty good the process of deceleration
and stem cell seating could ultimately
develop better replacement parts for the
heart these parts might prove more able
to repair themselves and could
theoretically grow with the young
patient to Harold this technique could
transform medicine last night we were
treating a patient who came in and
developed sudden onset heart failure and
is now currently on a machine that
supports our heart and lungs so seeing
these patients and seeing that clinical
need and you know these patients
families and understanding where all
this research funnels in to ultimately
which is helping patients and developing
tools to to improve lives of these
patients in end organ failure that's
that's really what gets us going I think
in what's what keeps us going